ukrainian soldiers have now pulled out
of the strategic city of illicit chance
as russian forces move one step closer
to capturing the entire donbass region
russia is calling those territorial
gains an important victory but as
redmond shannon reports they represent a
major come down from vladimir putin's
initial goals for the invasion
military protection in serene lugano
switzerland it's a pleasure to have you
here for a conference focused on
rebuilding ukraine the kremlin's goal is
the military
political
and economic destruction of ukraine
ukraine's prime minister says the full
long-term recovery bill may be close to
one trillion
dollars this support encourages us for
faster win it gave us hope to have
peaceful times and reconstruct and
recover my country dennis schmidhel
wants countries to follow canada's plan
to use frozen russian assets to pay for
some of that
the funds may one day be used here
luhansk region now completely under
russian control after ukrainian troops
withdrew from the city of lizzy chansk
the regional governor says his forces
could have held out for two or three
more weeks but would have ended up dying
for nothing luhansk is one of two
regions that make up the donbass in
ukraine's east the other is donetsk
russian-backed forces have controlled
parts of both since 2014 and russia
still only controls about half of
donetsk
vladimir putin described the advance as
a liberation
but four months into the invasion these
are scaled-back victories compared to
russia's initial plans every one of
these big battles uh lisi chance sevilla
donetsk mariupol they are long grinding
battles and the russians are paying
dearly for what they take analysts
believe the arrival of more advanced
western weapons could soon give ukraine
the upper hand as battles move into
donetsk
ukraine recently received these u.s
highmars rocket systems they need them
in much higher numbers if it's going to
make the kind of difference that uh
ukraine really needs for an outright
military victory and the ukrainians have
said as much ukraine's other problem
could be the manpower behind those
weapons as it reportedly deals with
ongoing heavy losses on the battlefront
redmond shannon global news london